yeah quadratic identities and heading
now we've looked at identities before
but not under this topic which topic
will be looked at again identities it
when you recognize away Chi guy didn't
he's very good okay
a trig identities it's the same kind of
ID your ever we have out the new kind of
notation right circle instance I could
say this okay this is not an equation an
equation is equal for such a values of X
good morning check certain values of X
so here's an equation right there's an
equation right sign x equals 1/2 it's
only true for certain values of X like
say 30 degrees and that's why we say ok
solve this right this doesn't have a
solution or more specifically it has an
infinite number solutions cuz you can
put any value of x in value like okay
you remember this side - yeah now we
also looked at this idea of moving trig
identities and I gave you a whole sort
of toolbox of like I don't know how many
do we get to by the end in 5 or 10 to 15
a large number of identities that you
can combine in different ways and we
were looking at proving identities that
was one step and then we move forward
into using identities you're these guys
right and I definitely like this what
would you put on the right-hand side
help me up sine a cos cos a summary
video you could write it the other way
but we tend to write it in order of the
angles so a and B a and B now the reason
why this is cool is actually some
reasons we haven't discovered yet but
the first thing we have uses for what we
call auxilary ankle
we could take a sum of two wave
functions something like this and then
we could go back with the rewind to take
a look you can think of it just as one
this is one way for you
so identities can yield you insight
alright identities about reshaping a
problem from something which it's like I
don't know how to work with this it was
something where you can work it ok so
that's kind of why we look at identities
in general um I remember when I first
want you Gatti's you have to prove them
all that these are the worst questions
ever because if mass is about finding
answers it's like if you do what the
answer is
what's the point of even doing it was
question right and the point is you're
trying to make this transition of
rephrasing something I think that's more
helpful to you ok so page 313 is what
you're looking at
I'm going to show you two ways of
proving let's go to central enemies
quadratic identities
one which is kind of like your standard
way the way you do about doing one of
these for treating and another way is a
little bit different which has
implications for later ok so let's have
a look at let's have a look at question
2 at the bottom of page 313 they give
you an identity they ask you to prove it
okay so let's write it out four stars
three thirty-year letter book oh yeah a
tie sorry that's a little one so I have
the older editions is it plus
is it Oh
so the difference I pulled between these
is the question is the the different
question they're answering is whether
these things true when are these things
true and this is true sometimes for 30
degrees and 150 degrees and 390 degrees
and whatever the next foot is okay 510
it's true sometimes this one true all
the time you can put any value of x in
it and it works yes yeah I noticed that
the fact is it actually is true for all
values of X that's why I've written it
okay yeah let's have a look at this
what do you begin right like I said this
is very much like the trig identities
that you've seen before okay
what will be your first instinct for
what you might write to start solving
this question that's your first instant
yeah me too left hand side left hand
side I think that would be my first
instinct as well
okay this is just the way we approach to
trig identities and we have categories
for this right look complicated side
simple side right so you're going to
work with this and simplify over to here
and that's all just fine let's give it a
shot okay it's not difficult you've got
this you just write it out first without
any kind of change
I see those denominators are just
opposites of each other so I can combine
them into one fraction if I just
multiply this fraction by minus one on
minus one okay so that's right so I'll
do that
okay so far so good oh just throwing
them together remember I'm trying to
show this trying to prove it so let's
keep any steps even if they seem quite
trivial because the result is a foregone
conclusion we don't get any marks but
just writing down the answer
you'll get rocks for showing you got
just the steps for getting it
okay what about gun here let's expand
out so 4x squared yeah I could finally
yeah okay so either way is fine take out
a factor of x 10 right what am I gonna
get we're going to get X by this a watch
the minus sign minus X plus minus X plus
because of that double negative all over
be like hey okay so whatever I got again
don't skip anything be - hey are you
happy with that
and then I can cancel just note though
why can't I cancel because I can't
always just cancel things out sometimes
I get something different why can I
cancel yeah
very good yeah like I said this is the
restriction now I sort of put this in a
slide there I know this the question
says a and B are distinct so they're not
equal to each other and they're nonzero
right
so therefore I can cancel B minus a
because it can't possibly be zero so I
can't multiply demos real time so I'm
gonna say to you the reason why is
because they're not the same great I'm
there